the United States is becoming very much
a despotic regime like the Communist
Chinese party dude they created the war
on terror it's the most generic title
imagine if they created the war on evil
do you think that they'll ever do that
then we're gonna get to a point where
they'll be like and enough people will
be like zealous and they'll be like yeah
yeah Evil's bad we gotta fight it
fascism the war on fashion the war on
carbon the war on chaos you know they're
gonna be like the war on evil
they're going to be like are you carbon
uh I don't know I think he's carbon get
him
they're gonna it's just so like it's so
subjective what's terrorism if people
were going to fight for the war on evil
they would we would have seen him step
up sooner the last three years
they're preparing people for some dumb
it's just so generic like it's just it's
just a reason to Rally people into
fighting to accepting curtailing rights
and empowering military-industrial
complex to build bigger bombs more
explosive and deadly weapons if they
just call it I mean it wasn't even a war